pardon me professor maybe you can help
me out here
is this word pronounced cash or cachet
cash appreciate it doc you see
when jack bailey pronounces a word he
pronounces it right
he can pronounce this thing smaragton
he can pronounce this thing sharon
schnitter
he even pronounces words that don't make
a lick of sense
albumin and when you're that damn good
with words
sooner or later someone's going to pay
you to say them
hi dr billy this is jack bailey
the official pronouncer of the national
spelling bee
luxembourg
l u x e
[Music]
gala sherbet
[Music]
gyro
gif before jock's days as the world's
foremost pronouncer of persnickety words
he began his spelling career on the
other side of the microphone
jock was a competitive speller and in
1980
he found himself in the finals of the
scripps national spelling bee
his word elucubrate
so he said e-l-u-c-u-b-r-a-t-e
and it means to burn the midnight oil to
study all night
and with those ten letters jock became a
champion
twenty-three years later jacquette
lucubrated all the way to the big show
propiophenone roqfert
pyroclastic can i please have the
definition
but sometimes even jock's meticulous
pronunciations don't tell the whole
story
english words are not always spelled as
they sound one thing that makes english
words really hard to spell
is the schwa
the schwa is that uh like in butter or
unutterable
the y and syringe the a in balloon
the o in they all sound the same spoken
out loud
a speller's nightmare the longer
and weirder a word is the easier it is
to spell take take the state fish of
hawaii the huma humanuku
the humahumanuka nuku that's an easy
word to spell
it's just long it's a weird word and
weird things stand out and are easier to
remember
o n o m a s i a paranormation
correct
for a man with perhaps the most
legitimate claim is the authority on
pronunciation
jock takes a rather agnostic approach
to the right and wrong ways to say
things a lot of people are kind of
amazed that i know how to pronounce all
these words
but i don't i read them from the
dictionary well how does the dictionary
know how to pronounce a word
because they go out there and listen to
native speakers
if there are a whole bunch of people who
pronounce a word a certain way that
makes it a correct pronunciation
people who have very strong opinions
that they're an incorrect way to
pronounce a word
but it's like saying that dog barked
wrong that's not a bark
well the dog gets to decide
thanks jock i reckon you got more wisdom
than all the books in the library
you